[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
Thanks for being here.
I'm Antony Passemard.
I lead the Product Management
team for Cloud IoT at Google.
And I'm joined by
a few folks here--
Sastry, the CTO
from FogHorn, Ramya,
VP of Product, and Scott
Bracken from Honeywell.
So we're going to
talk a little bit
about some of the
stuff we've been doing
with FogHorn and Honeywell.
So a bit of an agenda, a
little overview of Google
and how we see IoT, fairly
high level and generic
view of IoT for us.
And then FogHorn will come on
stage and talk about their edge
solution and their
IoT core, integration
which is pretty cool.
You'll see some of the
platform, and they're
going to talk about a use case
they've done with Honeywell.
And they actually
have a nice demo here
to show you what they've done,
which is really impressive
and I think adds a lot of value.
So we'll have the demo
and Q&A at the end,
so I hope you enjoy.
So you're probably here because
you all know that IoT can
and probably is already bringing
value to your businesses.
And whether it's to
solve something specific
or really being part of a
broader digital transformation,
it's really central to a lot
of creating differentiation
for your businesses and
across the industries.
We see that in agriculture,
really increasing crop yield
or lowering energy
consumption in oil and gas,
doing predictive maintenance
or security in oil and gas.
We've seen some of
those use cases.
We're seeing logistics
to do high value asset
tracking or better driving
behaviors for fleets,
reducing risks for the drivers.
So we see a lot of
those use cases.
So almost across every industry,
we're seeing IoT use cases.
What we've seen also--
that's a study that came out.
This is a IoT
analytics company that
does a bunch of
competitive intelligence
on IoT in different sectors.
And what they're saying is in
2021, about 50% of the company
will have IoT projects
and will have seen value.
So it's more than
having a project.
It's actually seeing
value from IoT in 2021.
That's only two years from now.
But what's staggering is
difference from 2018 to 2021.
There's a massive
difference, a massive growth
in the realization
of value through IoT,
which is the big change here.
I'm going to talk a
little bit about real-time
in some of the talk because
we're seeing that speed
is really critical in IoT.
We've seen analytics done
on bulk data on database,
and that's great to
build your models.
But what we're
seeing from customers
is really the demand
for real-time insights
and real-time actionable
insight, actually.
And what's important,
we're seeing that data.
By 2025, a quarter of the data
will be real-time in nature.
That's quite a lot.
But that's part of
that quarter of data,
and 95% of is actually IoT data.
That's real time IoT data
from the global datasphere,
they call it.
It's kind of funky
word but interesting.
So real-time nature, being able
to take decision right there
on the spot, either
locally or in the cloud,
is super important
for an IoT platform.
And it's more important
even because you
want to get that accuracy to
reduce costs, drive efficiency
on a manufacturing line,
to simplify your logistics
and reduce risk, and make your
environment work more safe.
So that's something we've
seen in oil and gas,
in particular, to track
workers with their hat
and being in zones
they're supposed to be
and things like that.
This is vision intelligence
applied to a work environment
for safety use cases.
That has to happen
all in real-time.
You can't wait for the
next day to say, hey,
you shouldn't be in there.
The accident happens,
it's too late.
One thing that we've noticed--
and I've been a cloud IoT
space for quite some time now,
and I've seen it going through a
lot of cycles of PoC and pilots
and testing out stuff.
I think that's changing.
Now I'm seeing the PoCs and
the pilots go to production.
And that's a big shift
that we're seeing.
We're seeing those growth.
People in companies-- I've
been testing IoT for a while.
Now they realize what
they can do with it,
and now it's going
in production.
That's the big
shift we're seeing.
And the problem is you really
have to think about, OK, I am I
doing my IoT project
in isolation?
Am I using the right platform?
Am I limited by the
platform I'm using?
Am I restricting
my possibilities
with a platform I chose?
So choosing the provider
of your IoT platform
is actually really
important, and you often
time forget about the delays of
managing complex infrastructure
when you put IoT
platform in place.
The specialized
tech and learning
curve you have to have for
hardware communication, AI,
data ingestion, all
of that, there's
no real standard protocols.
So it's pretty messy.
There's a lot of hidden costs
that come with IoT deployment.
So having a platform that's
simple, flexible, and can
really help you to
get to value faster
is critical for the success.
We see IoT from
Google's [INAUDIBLE]..
But we see IoT as a big
data challenge almost more
than anything else, and
big data in real-time.
And having that ability to gain
real-time insight, as I said,
will bring the
competitiveness that you're
looking for your business.
So in terms of platform, the
Google Cloud IoT platform
is a serverless platform from
connectivity, processing,
storage, and analyze.
Serverless means
that you never have
to worry about
scaling up or down
or pre-provisioning resources
and overusing resources.
It's just going to scale
from one or a few device
to millions of
devices very easily.
And that's really a core
differentiation of our platform
from connectivity to analysis.
If we look a little bit deeper
into the Cloud IoT platform
itself, you're going to see
several components here.
The main one is Cloud IoT Core.
That's something we launched
GA last year in March,
so about a year ago.
That's been pretty successful.
This is a global front end for
your devices, one URL globally.
And we use all the
Google front end--
the GFE, we call
them-- to ingest data
from anywhere in the world.
You don't really
have to think about,
where is my device physically
and which region does
it have to connect to to
have the lowest latency.
That will happen automatically.
This is served by the same
front end that serve your Google
search or your YouTube.
It's the same front end.
So it's really global, really
scalable all across the globe.
Once the data flows into IoT
Core, it flows into Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is this messaging
bus, global again.
Also realize, you don't have
to worry about resources here.
Pub/Sub is available globally.
That means that if you have data
ingested in Australia, in Asia,
in North America, they all
fall into a topic of choice.
You want to get that data,
just query that topic
and get the data out.
You don't have to think about,
oh, where is my device again.
It's all global infrastructure,
automatically scalable.
Pub/Sub stores data
for seven days.
You can do snapshot replays and
have several subscribers to it
and get the data out.
The data can go into
a Cloud function,
a serverless compute
service to trigger actions,
or do any kind of requests.
Or it can go to
Cloud Data Fusion.
Our Cloud Data Fusion is
the managed version of CDAP.
CDAP is an open source
data processing pipeline.
You may know it as Cask.io.
So that's open source, and
you can create your workflow
with drag and drop little nodes,
and then do your transformation
along the way.
Plug the data out of Pub/Sub,
do your transformation,
and drop it in some database.
If you want to do
longer processes
like windowing
analysis in real-time,
you can use Dataflow.
Dataflow is also
scalable on its own
and has an Apache Beam
open source equipment.
All those are managed but have
their open source equivalents.
Pretty cool.
And then you'll land in Bigtable
if you want to do time series.
If you want to do
big data analytics,
you have your BigQuery.
You have Cloud Machine
Learning to do your training.
Send those models back, and
send them back to the device
because Cloud IoT Core
is bi-directional.
And then you have some
nice visualization tools.
So that's what we call
the Cloud IoT platform.
Putting that together
is fairly simple.
Doesn't require much
code, if any code.
It's all serverless.
And we're pretty happy with
some of the early customers
that we've had.
You can see some
of those customer
at the spotlight
session on Thursday.
We have some of the
customer on stage.
One key element of our strategy
with Google Cloud IoT Platform
is we can't do it on our own.
We have to have partners
working with us.
And I'm really
happy today to have
FogHorn as one of our partners,
if Sastry wants to join me.
FogHorn, we've been
working with them
for over a year at the
Edge, in particular,
and solving some of
our Edge challenges
and doing machine
learning at the Edge.
So thank you, and I'll
leave it up you, Sastry.
SASTRY MALLADI:
Thank you, Antony.
Is my mic on?
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
Yeah, you're on.
SASTRY MALLADI: Good evening
or good afternoon, everyone.
I know I'm between
you and food, so I'll
try to be as
interesting as possible.
So we are a Google
partner, as you mentioned,
and we are an edge computing
platform provider company.
We are a value-based company.
I'm going to give you a
snapshot of who we are.
We're based in Sunnyvale,
right here in the valley.
We provide software that runs
on small devices, edge devices,
whether they're existing PLCs,
gateways, or embedded systems
close to the machines,
close to the assets.
And the key here is to do live
data processing, analytics,
and machine learning on the data
that's flowing through the edge
to derive actionable insights.
We've got customers across
the globe, hundreds of them.
We've got lots of analyst
coverage, and so on.
Everyone that you
see here, the logos,
these are all our investors.
Honeywell is an investor.
Honeywell is actually
going to talk today
about how they're leveraging our
technology for some of the use
cases as well.
You can see all of the big
technology and industrial names
there as well that
all are investors.
Traditionally, we have
been shipping our products
on Gateways, PLCs,
Raspberry Pis, things
of that nature, where you have
a flavor of Linux or Windows
or a real-time operating system.
What we have recently also done
is release the same product
on hand-held devices,
which is actually
the core part of the demo
and discussion today,
on Android-based devices.
So the way the
product works is--
this is how it looks like.
You have a tool
here in the cloud,
which you use to manage
all of the edge devices.
The software runs on
the edge device itself.
We have a very flexible
microservices-based
architecture.
In the traditional Linux
world, we have used containers.
Obviously, in Android,
there are no containers.
So we have developed
all of this as an app.
So the notion that
you can have all kinds
of data that fed into our
system through a database
that we have--
the two core key components
here are the analytics engine
and the edge ML, the
machine running engine.
The idea being that as
you're ingesting live data
from all different
sources, you can
apply analytics and machine
learning on the data
to drive the insights.
And then you can take
closed loop control actions
by either using our SDK.
There is an SDK using which
you can build applications.
Or you can also visualize
it and send that information
into IoT Core and
other places as well.
So maybe let's
step back a second.
A lot of you, I'm sure--
many of you are familiar
with edge computing.
But let's step back for a second
to say, why is edge actually
important.
Right?
So in a typical
industrial environment,
whether it's in oil and gas,
manufacturing, transportation,
smart cities, buildings,
doesn't matter.
All of these different sectors,
you've got data coming in--
I might add-- lots
of data, especially
if you're doing video, audio,
and acoustic type of data.
And there is a high cost latency
and security associated with it
by directly connecting these
machines into some kind
of a central or cloud location.
What FogHorn really does
is to help with that,
solve the problem, by
introducing this edge device
next to the asset-- on many
cases on the asset itself--
where the data is ingested
into our software running here.
And then you derive the insights
and then send the results
and insights back
into the cloud,
wherefore additional
processing for fine tuning
your models, for fleet-wide
visibility, and so on.
This obviously has the
benefits of low latency
here because there is no latency
involved between these two.
And then there is low
cost of data transport.
And then security is also
eliminated or minimized
when you're
communicating with that.
Another way to look at it,
a lot of the times when
you're processing data--
in this example right here,
this is a sensor signal for one
of the signals.
You see here how the
blips are in the signal?
This is a suction pump.
When you typically
send that information
to a down sampled environment,
whether it's cloud data center,
this signal actually
looks like that.
You actually pretty much miss
the little point of what it is.
So the fidelity of deriving
actionable insights at the edge
is a lot higher, is really why
it's so important, in addition
to all of the
three things that I
talked about-- security, cost,
and, of course, latencies.
This is a high level
product solution,
which is our traditional
solution that we've
been shipping on Linux.
It's the same solution that I
showed you on the first slide.
It has been put onto Android.
The idea here is being
that you ingested data
from all these different
types of sources,
enrich them because a lot of the
times in the industrial world,
the data quantity is not good.
That layer fixes all of
that, cleanses, normalizes,
decodes it, and then does
processing through these two
layers that I talked about.
And then the information
itself can then be published
to a cloud environment.
We have pretty deep
integration with IoT Core,
as Antony mentioned,
and I'll mentioned
that in a second in the next
slide how that is done as well.
And using the SDK, you can then
program and programmatically
subscribe to those insights
and take closed loop actions.
So one concept that I want
to bring into this picture
is this notion of what
is called edgification.
I know it's a new word.
So what is edgification?
A lot of the times when
you build data science
models, machine learning models,
to run in a server environment,
cloud environment,
you may or may not
necessarily pay attention to
the amount of compute resources.
Or you may be actually
working on batch data
rather than working
on live data.
And you may also
not pay attention
to the number of layers
on the size of the model
because those are
not necessarily
the constraints you worry
about in a cloud environment.
But when you bring the same
model to run on an edge
environment, in order to
run efficiently and also
perform at the rate
that you would expect,
you have to deal
with those things.
And that process is what
we call edgification.
How do you take your model
that typically works off
of batch data and make it
run on real-time live data?
How do you then
optimize and reduce
the number of
layers and the rates
and still with the
same level of accuracy?
And finally, if we look at the
anatomy of a machine learning
model, it has
really three things.
One is what we call a
pre-processing code, which
is really feature extraction.
Let's say you're
looking at a video
or you're looking at some sensor
signals from the machines.
Before you can apply a machine
learning model and algorithm,
you've got to extract
some features.
And that's typically what
we call pre-processing,
and that is the most
compute-intensive part of it.
And then followed by you've
passed those features
into your machine learning
algorithm or the equation,
which itself is not really
that computationally intensive.
And then followed
by post-processing,
which is how do you then take
the results of that equation
and do something with it.
What we do as part of
this edgification process
is to extract all of
the pre-processing,
the post-processing, into our
highly efficient complex event
processing engine that we
built from ground up, which
runs in really, really small
footprint, few megabytes
of memory, runs really fast.
And then lead the machine
learning part [INAUDIBLE] to it
into your engine.
Of course, you also have
the ability to, in fact,
do the machine learning part
in the CEP engine itself
as we move forward.
Here are some examples where
we took a video-based layer
modeling use case,
how you can actually
optimize when you build.
Take a model that is
built here, edgify it.
You got almost a 10x
or higher improvement,
and yet, much higher fertility,
much higher accurate results.
Now, even when you build
a machine learning model
to derive some insights
and predict some things
and you deploy this in
the edge environment
or any environment
for that matter,
and it's accurately
predicting the results,
it does not
necessarily mean over
time it's going to
continue to predict
with the same level of accuracy.
Because of data drifts, because
of changes in machine behavior,
the same model that once used to
accurately predict the results
may no longer do that.
So how do we address that?
How do we fix?
That to address that, we came
up with this notion of automated
closed loop machine learning.
So what does that really mean?
So as you see here
in our architecture,
once a model is
deployed, we built
this thing called a prediction
model degradation detector.
What that module does is
that it continuously measures
several different factors--
whether it's an F1
score, whether it's
a data distribution
collection of how things are--
and tries to see if the accuracy
of the model that you're
predicting is deviating
from what it was before.
And when it does, what
it does it automatically
sends that information to
the Google IoT Core here.
From Google IoT Core,
as Antony explained,
it's a Pub/Sub system.
You can send that information
to Dataflow, which can then
be read and configured into
BigQuery in the Cloud ML engine
where you retrain
incrementally your model
with this incremental
data that's coming in.
And then push that model
back onto the edge as well.
This is all automated.
Of course, you have an
option to not automate it.
But this is done
in an automated way
until the accuracy comes
back to what it was before.
And this is what we have been
calling the closed loop ML.
I know different
terminology have been used.
This is truly revolutionizing
the edge computing
because you're actually
introducing the notion of AI,
artificial intelligence, onto
these edge devices on how
do you self-correct
the models deployed
onto this environment
in order for you
to continue to predict this
with the same level of accuracy.
As you can see, our solution
is a genetic platform.
We have been deploying
this across many, many use
cases across many
different verticals.
Our top verticals
actually include
manufacturing-- a lot
of big name customers--
oil and gas, transportation,
smart cities, buildings.
We have done other things as
well like mining, and so on.
What I want to do is
just mention a couple
of use cases quickly here,
one in the manufacturing,
one in oil and
gas, that actually
involves different paradigms.
This is a fact that I
can publicly reference.
It's a GE factory.
They manufacture these
industrial gated capacitors
that look like this.
This is a highly
expensive capacitor
that are used in power plants.
The material cost alone is
several thousand dollars.
And the way the
processing includes
was, they take an aluminum
foil, they wind it
through what is called a winding
machine called [INAUDIBLE]
winding machine.
And the winding
machine itself has
hundreds of sensors
that are continuously
measuring several things,
winder tension, width aspect
ration, and so on.
Once they wind it, they press it
into packs and then insert it.
These are those packs.
And they run it through what is
called a treat oven to take out
all the moisture content.
And finally, they'll fill
oil into the capacitor
to test the capacitor.
At this point, if
the capacitor fails,
so it's not working or
seeing dielectric failures,
it's too late in the process.
And that's exactly what was
happening in the factory.
As I walked into the
factory, I see a lot of pink
slips on the factory floor,
costing them a lot of scrap,
millions of dollars.
So the challenge
posed for us was,
how do we connect our edge
solution to the sensors
directly into this assembly
line in the machine,
connect it and identify
exactly what was causing
these dielectric failures,
more importantly, before it
is too late so that the operator
actually has a chance to go
take the units offline
and then fix it.
And that's what we have
been able to successfully do
that and reduce all of their
pain points on the scrap.
The second use case I want
to talk about is interesting.
This is an oil and gas use case.
Saudi Aramco is one
of our customers.
Many other customers as well.
We've actually publicly talked
about this at the RC conference
a couple of months ago.
This is, as some of you
may be familiar with,
in oil and gas refineries,
gas is being refined.
You've got hundreds
of compressors.
And because of various
reasons, excessive pressure,
sometimes other reasons,
compressor failures, the gas
gets released in through
what are called oil stacks.
These are all oil stacks.
And then the gas gets burned.
When gas gets burned,
you see a fire.
What's worse, you can
see smoke sometimes.
Fire itself is bad.
Smoke is even worse.
Dark smoke is even worse.
So how to identify?
Up until before this
edge solution came up,
typically, they
installed video cameras.
Sometimes they
don't even do that.
And a human being is able
to monitor it 24 by 7,
which is not really practical.
All they can do is to
see, oh, there is fire.
There is smoke.
What we have done is
installed our software
on a controller box attached
to these oil stacks--
many, many, many of them--
and then directly take
the video feed from this,
combine it with the audio
feed of the compressor,
and identify and
correlate one, there
is in fact a flare
or a smoke and also
compute the volumetric flow
of the gas that is burned,
and things of that nature.
So human being and monitoring
of this is eliminated.
But more importantly,
operator gets an alert
when there is a real problem,
and we get to the root cause
and why the problem
was occurring.
This is being widely deployed
in a very popular use case.
One last thing I want to say is
that this particular session,
the rest of the
talk and the demo,
remember as we talked
about, is our product that
was released on the handheld
devices, mobile edge platforms.
We have noticed that
there is obviously
a lot of traction in
this field because these
are all battery-powered devices,
which makes it even more
important for our edge computing
to consume less and less power,
less and less CPU and memory.
And we imported our
software onto these devices.
And deploying with Honeywell,
especially initially working
with Honeywell
device where we have
done a couple of use cases,
which we'll demonstrate today
as well.
With that, I'd like to invite
Scott Bracken, Director
of Advanced Technology
from Honeywell,
to speak about their technology.
SCOTT BRACKEN: Great, thank you.
Thank you, Sastry.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Scott Bracken,
as Sastry mentioned,
and I lead the
Advanced Technology
Group for the Productivity
Products team within Honeywell.
And I'd like to introduce you
to the corporation of Honeywell
a little bit to explain where
the Productivity Products
group sits within Honeywell.
It's an exciting time to
be an engineer at Honeywell
because there's a significant
amount of growth being driven
by technology in these
four business segments that
Honeywell exists, aerospace,
home and building technologies,
safety and productivity
solutions--
which is the group I'm from,
and I'll explain a little more
about that in a moment--
and the performance
materials group.
The one common thing that
connects all of these systems
or all of these business
groups is the fact
that connected
solutions are what's
driving the growth in all
of these business areas.
And therefore, the technology
development within Honeywell
is able to develop
common platforms
across these
different businesses.
And as I mentioned, we've
been growing significantly
in the technology area and
most specifically transforming
the Honeywell corporation to a
software industrial business.
The point of this
slide is to point out
that we have already invested
heavily in software engineering
talent within our corporation
to build that capability.
Now diving a little bit
deeper into the safety
and productivity
solutions group,
you can see that
there's a lot of areas
within the industrial
sector where
technology can help our
customers be more productive.
First in the connected worker.
Many wearable devices
that an employee
can wear in a industrial setting
can help monitor for safety
and to help that employee
be more productive.
In the supply chain
and logistics area,
there's a tremendous
amount of data
that is important
to our end customers
for managing the efficiency
of their operations.
In the distribution
center themselves,
we have a lot of automation
that we've introduced
and provide to
our customer base,
again, for reducing
their cost of operations
and being more efficient.
And finally, we also have a
very wide portfolio of sensors,
primarily for
safety applications.
Pressure sensors and gas
detection type sensors
are quite prominent
in that portfolio,
but we have sensors that
support all of the different IoT
applications across this suite.
So once again,
diving a little bit
deeper into the Honeywell
technology area, specifically
in productivity
products, what am I
talking about in that realm?
There's several
different solutions,
and many customers use this
technology in different ways.
But we can provide
common platforms
across these use cases to
provide those customers
with the unique
needs that they have,
yet with the power of having
a very robust solution
underneath.
Things such as vehicle-mounted
computers, all types
of asset tracking technologies.
Particularly, RFID
sensing is seeing
a growth spurt in recent years.
This is not just limited to
some of the industrial settings
but also spills over into
retail quite prominently.
And then looking at the
solutions on the right-hand
of this chart,
scanning is really
at the core of what we do in
our productivity products group.
Product identification,
primarily with barcodes,
is what our scanning
devices is centered around.
And then we provide value on top
of that with other solutions,
such as voice solutions to
allow for hands-free operation
of product identification, the
mobile computers, which I'll
go into in a little
more detail in a moment,
and then, of course,
different tagging
that we can use for sensing
the devices in any kind
of inventory setting.
That all gets tied
together, obviously,
in a cloud environment for
data management and inventory
tracking purposes.
And most recently, in
fact, in the last year,
our flagship device was
recently introduced.
We call it our
Mobility Edge platform,
and it's a unified platform
for mobile computing.
It's based on the Android or
it's an Android-based device,
and it's purpose built for
these industrial applications.
The rugged sized design
of not only the form
factor being very
familiar to employees
but also allowing for a very
heavy use during a workday.
As I mentioned, product
identification and barcode
scanning is the core
operation of these devices,
but that can take place
thousands of times a day
or thousands of times
in a single shift.
So building a device that can
handle that kind of workload,
survive the entire shift,
is a very critical aspect
of our customer requirements.
So withstanding the
harsh environment,
whether it's impact or whether
it's the elements, even
moisture, say, a
rainy environment--
it can also withstand.
We've used the Android
operating system, obviously,
for easy field deployment.
And giving us a seamless
operation with the cloud
connectivity.
And we built this device
with multiple form factors,
but underneath the hood is
a single common hardware
platform.
And I particularly
like this slide myself
because I'm surrounded
by software engineers,
but actually I'm a hardware
engineer at my roots.
And so I have to show at least
one slide with a processor
module on it.
And we're quite proud
of this processor module
that we introduced with
the Mobility Edge platform
last year because it is
common throughout all
the different form factors of
the different mobile devices
that we provide to
our customer base.
And particularly,
I'm excited today
to be on stage with
Google and with FogHorn
because now that we've
deployed this edge
device, this
platform, we now can
build a tremendous
amount of value
within that software
on top of that device.
And the first place we started
or one of the first places
we started is looking for this
very thin layer that Sastry
has already
described, that allows
us to build the AI
and machine learning
toolset and capability on top
of these Mobility Edge devices.
And FogHorn's Lightning
offering meets
all of those requirements
for our needs
across our entire customer set.
So now the last
couple of slides,
before I hand it
off to the demo,
are just describing
the use cases
that we are first investing in.
The first one is quite
an interesting one to us
because we have a rich
history of designing
a very sophisticated
software tool, decoder tool,
to extract from
an image a barcode
and decode it for that
customer's application.
But on the edge of
that application
and during different use
cases, many of the images
we receive from our
device on our imager come
in very blurry or very noisy.
It's very common.
New operators that
haven't operated a scanner
before don't necessarily
aim the device accurately.
Or I'm sure many of you
have been at a retail store
when a particular
packaging, maybe
a shrink wrapped packaging
that has some ripple in it,
is causing the scan to
be difficult to read
for that device.
And an operator,
naturally many times,
wants to go closer to that
barcode to pick up that scan.
And in fact, they're making it
more blurry by going closer.
So again, there's several
different environments
where a blurry barcode or being
able to decode a blurry barcode
would be much more efficient
for our customer base.
And what you see
here is a data set.
So we created a synthetic data
set of 50,000 barcode images.
They are image
pairs, clean images
and blurry or damaged images.
And we use that for training
our machine learning model
that then we deploy
through the FogHorn system
onto our Mobility Edge device.
And these are just some
snippets of the images that were
part of our training data set.
So that's our first use
case, and our second one
is quite basic but very
important to our customers.
So these devices are
owned by the customer.
They're not owned
by the employee.
They're not their
personal devices.
So the typical method
for these being deployed
is at the beginning of
a shift, the operator
will take the device, use
it throughout the shift,
and then dock it for
charging overnight.
The very simple
requirement is this
that device must
operate continuously
throughout that entire shift.
That shift can vary in time.
It can vary in operation and
what modes are being used.
And so by applying the machine
learning type of approach
to this and working with the
data scientists at FogHorn,
we're able to create a real-time
operating model on the Mobility
Edge device that can
monitor and optimize
to extend the life of that
battery for that device
during the shift.
So with that, I'd like
to invite Ramya up
from FogHorn, VP of Products,
to take us through the demo.
RAMYA RAVICHANDAR:
All right, I'm here
to tell you that it's real.
So this is the Honeywell device.
It's a CT60, and our
FogHorn Lightning Mobile
is actually running on this.
So following up from
Scott's talk, what I will
a demo here are the two apps.
One is the battery insights
app, and the other one
is the barcode optimization.
But before I jump to the
app, what I do want to do--
I am a products person--
is go through our
FogHorn manager here.
So what do you see
on the left side here
is our FogHorn manager portal.
So think of it as our remote
management configuration
monitoring console that lets you
see all the edge devices that
have the Lightning Mobile
or the Lightning stack
installed on it.
One of the things
we do at FogHorn
is be very focused
on the OT persona.
We understand the
users of our product
are operators in the
manufacturing floor,
your refinery technician.
And so a lot of
what we put in here
is focused on that persona.
So especially in
manufacturing, the idea
is to create this
one golden edge
configuration that can
work across massive volumes
of devices.
And so this FogHorn
manager portal
lets you create
that configuration.
Whether it's to
add a new sensor,
define analytic expressions that
do complex event processing,
or come up with machine
learning models, all of that
is packaged up really
nicely into a configuration
and deployed onto the device.
And so that's what
we've done here.
So you can see
the two solutions,
which is the barcode enhancer
and the battery insights.
Here are the two models that
are part of this configuration.
And now, that's what's
deployed on this device.
So let me pull up
the FogHorn app.
So you can see the
FogHorn app here
that's installed on this device.
And immediately, we have
the two solutions pop up,
which is the barcode enhancer
and the battery insights.
Now, Scott did talk about the
goal of using battery insights,
and I'll talk a little bit about
the metrics that show up here.
So both of these apps represent
two classes of learning,
so to speak.
In the battery
insights app, it's
an adaptive learning model
that's going on on this device.
So it's learning on the fly
based on the pattern of usage.
How often is the
battery charged?
How long is the work shift?
How does the user
actually use it?
What we are building is
a very unique fingerprint
of device usage that is
specific to this unit.
So the metric here is saying,
yeah, it's OK for the shift.
This battery is going to
last for the next 16 hours.
Oh, by the way,
I also inform you
that your work shift
is around eight hours.
So this model is going to get
better and better as the device
gets used over time.
Now, if you move on
to the next one, which
is the barcode enhancer, it
happens behind the scenes.
So this is an operator.
He has the scanner.
He's scanning the barcode.
And the goal is to have that
first scan be successful.
And in the event that
Scott talked about,
the image is
grainy, what happens
is that gets passed
to the FogHorn stack,
and we're running
this neural net model.
So the difference
in the model is
that's a neural net model
built using TensorFlow, running
on TensorFlow Lite.
And the inferencing is
happening on the device.
So to help demonstrate
how the barcodes actually
look before and after the neural
net model runs through it,
I'll actually go through a
barcode viewer enhancer app
here.
All right.
So on the top here, you
see the before picture.
This is what the operator
is actually seeing
when they scan the barcode.
And once it passes through the
Lightning Mobile stack here,
this is the result. There is
definitely much more clarity,
and more importantly, there's
no loss of productivity
when the operator tries
to do that first scan.
There's no manual
re-entry of the code.
So let me go through a
couple of more images.
This is an example of
a full barcode sample,
and this is the clarifying
one through our stack.
This is one of my favorites.
It's a piece of the barcode.
I didn't think I'd ever say
I have a favorite barcode,
but here it is.
There we go, and I think they'll
do that as the last one here.
So the point of
this presentation
is to say that we
have Lighting Mobile,
and we have the ability to
now run on Honeywell devices
with the Google Cloud
technique of building AI models
on their data science platform.
What does it do for us
as industrial operators,
as industrial users?
It opens up this whole
universe, this whole expanse
of use cases.
Sastry talked a little bit
about sensor fusion in the past,
that it's the ability to combine
video, audio, structured data.
What are the newer insights?
For example, if you're
from oil and gas,
and you have a
technician walking around
in your refinery, he could
take an Android mobile device,
point at a valve, and
really get insight
about should this
valve be on or off.
The question to ask
oneself is, what
is a use case today that's
tethering my operator to maybe
a location.
Instead, with the use
of Android devices,
it's now more liberating
and therefore,
the ability to get
newer insights.
[MUSIC PLAYING]